we're at the Javits Center its new york
comicon is the epicenter for TV movies
video games comic books anything you
could want it's all here but if you're
not here you're in luck we got you
covered
so Tony what was the coolest thing you
saw the convention this weekend coolest
things probably the ages of shield
interview press room that's always cool
Gabriel Luna had a little
remote-controlled charger like his car
and show really cool artist alley was
always awesome jam-packed lots of cool
are we got a lot of cool art new and
improved may be improved mr. our
challenge cool things lots of lots of
stuff
Joey's go Sonny what was the coolest
thing you saw in New York Comic Con Amen
all right well East Coast tony is here
to cover the video game part of
comic-con the best thing I saw was John
wick chronicles that's on the HTC vive
is amazing if you want to be John wick
that is the game to do it you've got the
guns in your hands you're picking up
guns if you want different ones you're
tossing it down to the ground and
reloading you're on a rooftop you're
shooting dudes you're shooting down a
helicopter it's awesome if you want to
be John wick you can and it feels great
all right Matt same question what's the
best thing you saw well I was super
excited to interview Andy Serkis you and
I got trapped in his green room we did
we wound up in Andy circuses private
room with some personal friends of his
super awkward but he was a super nice
guy I also got to interview Jason David
Frank who was the green ranger on Power
Rangers I'm very excited I didn't get
beaten up because he was doing some like
karate moves throughout the interview
it's like them they just kind of walk in
the show floor kind of taking it all in
and tons of cosplayers which is always
fun
for more news videos cosplay keep it
tuned to gamespot com